Un, deux, trois.
Je n'ai pas appuyé
au bon moment.
Pardon !
Un, deux, trois.
Oui, elle est bien.
- On fonce ?
On cavale ?
- Ce qui est génial,
c'est qu'ils adorent poser.
Vous êtes horrible.
Ça brûle.
Merci.
- Je t'en prie.
On se met là, c'est bien ?
- Un, deux, trois,
quatre, cinq, six, sept, huit.
Un, deux, trois,
Un, deux,
cinq, six, sept.
Tu poses, Tom.
Un, deux, trois,
quatre, cinq, six, sept, huit.
Un.
Tu attrapes le haut
de ta tête et tu pars en arrière.
Si, tu y arrives.
Il faut que tu les retiennes.
Tu dois les redescendre tout de suite.
On refait
l'enchaînement jusqu'à un.
Cinq, six, sept, huit.
Un, deux, trois,
quatre, cinq, six, sept, huit.
Un.
Il faut mimer.
Là, je vous avais dit que
c'était le doigt dans l'eau.
Pensez à ça,
le petit doigt dans l'eau.
Puis, regardez au-dessus de la main.
Un,
sept, huit.
cinq, six.
Tom, Jean-Philippe et Fabrice
sont arrivés au premier entraînement.
Je pense qu'à la base,
c'était plus pour des essais.
Pour essayer la synchro
parce qu'ils ne connaissaient pas.
Sachant qu'ils viennent
de la natation sportive à la base,
ils y ont pris goût assez rapidement.
Dans le sens où ils ont voulu
faire un trio assez rapidement
parce que déjà,
ils s'entendaient bien.
Ils se sont aperçus qu'ils avaient
les mêmes qualités dans l'eau.
- Pas tes cuisses, JP.
Oui, ici.
Tom, gaine ton corps.
- On n'est pas arrivé.
- Allez, vas-y.
Oui, mais bloque
au niveau des fessiers.
Oui, c'est ça.
C'est ça.
Serre tes jambes.
Oui, c'est ça.
Ce sont les trois à la suite, Tom.
- Quoi ?
- Il n'y a pas d'arrêt.
Ce sont les trois.
Tu coules, tu remontes.
Tu pousses.
Baisse tes épaules, JP.
- Au début, on n'avait
pas trop d'objectifs en synchro.
On s'est dit qu'on allait commencer
déjà par apprendre certaines choses.
Moi, j'en ai déjà fait un tout
petit peu pendant deux semaines
quand j'ai fait ma formation d'éducateur
sportif dans les activités de la natation
où j'ai fait du plongeon,
de la natation synchronisée,
du water-polo et de la natation de course.
Je connaissais quelques trucs.
C'était très difficile.
C'est de là que je m'étais dit,
respect pour les filles.
Entre l'apnée, les comptes, la musique
et le physique, c'est super dur.
- Non, on descend droit.
Vous sentez quand
vous êtes sous l'eau à la fin.
- C'est plus long.
- Oui, c'est plus long.
C'est ce qu'il y a
de plus dur à contrôler.
Les fins de figure.
On descend droit, grouper
et pivoter, on repart en brasse.
Faites attention à ça.
Vous serrez trop, je ne dois pas vous voir
comme des pingouins en l'air, comme ça.
Baissez les épaules,
serrez les omoplates et levez la tête.
Tout doucement.
Oui, vas-y.
Tu restes un peu en flamenco, Tom.
Tire sur tes genoux,
tout doucement, ballet leg.
Doucement,
tire sur ton genou à la verticale.
Bloque ta cuisse
pour le voilier maintenant.
Très bien.
On s'étire.
Non, regarde.
Remets-toi en ballet leg.
- Je sais qu'il faut
faire un angle droit, mais...
- Allez vas-y,
juste pour finir la longueur.
Vas-y, pousse-toi
du mur, mets-toi en godille.
Pousse par là-bas.
Vas-y,
continue à avancer.
Étire ton torse et tire ta tête.
Finis en godille.
- Au début, on était
fixé sur un ballet d'équipe.
On ne savait pas trop, Gigi non plus.
Hélène ne savait pas trop
ce qu'on allait faire,
où ça allait nous mener.
Puis, on a commencé,
là, Gigi, nous disait à JP
et à Fabrice qu'on était...
Enfin, on a intégré les choses très
facilement et très rapidement aussi.
JP un jour, il m'a dit,
on va faire un trio.
J'ai vu avec Gigi
et j'aimerais bien qu'on fasse un trio.
J'ai fait, oui, pourquoi pas.
Moi, tout de suite, j'étais partant.
Je me suis dit, c'est bien,
on y va, on fait un trio.
- Ce qui était important pour nous,
c'était de faire
quelque chose d'un peu original,
c'est-à-dire de la natation
synchronisée entre hommes.
On voulait que ce soit
de la natation synchronisée entre hommes.
On ne voulait pas,
ni des chorégraphies,
ni des musiques
qui soient trop féminines.
- Ça me parait bizarre, c'est ça ?
- Pas du tout.
- Là, superbe.
Vous avez vu la piscine.
- Oui, on entend bien la musique.
- Le fait qu'une équipe soit
constituée uniquement d'hommes,
cela faisait qu'elle n'était pas
validée par la fédération française.
Paris aquatique, il y a quelques
années, en 2000 ou un peu après 2000,
a créé sa première équipe
de natation synchronisée masculine
et s'est battu pour que cette équipe
soit reconnue dans le réseau fédéral.
On a eu gain de cause
parce que normalement,
toute équipe constituée
que de garçons, n'était pas reconnue.
Elle ne pouvait donc pas participer
au championnat de France et autres.
Je pense qu'il est important qu'une
personne comme Gigi se soit battue
pour faire reconnaître
la natation synchronisée masculine
quel que soit son niveau,
mais il faut
qu'il n'y ait pas de barrières au sexe.
- Ça va, Olivia ?
Mets-toi là, ma puce.
Sébastien, tu reviens ?
Des fois, il est un peu perdu
au milieu de toutes ces filles.
Regarde, viens voir.
Mets-toi dos à moi.
Là, il faut que tu étires.
C'est ta nuque.
Baisse tes épaules à fond.
Renvoie tes épaules en arrière.
Fais de la godille avec tes bras.
Tes mains doivent être symétriques.
Tes mains sont en godilles pour t'aider.
C'est en même temps.
Maintenant, tu vas
mettre ton dos bien droit.
Allez, vas-y.
Baisse tes épaules, étire ta nuque.
Non, étire ta nuque.
Il ne faut pas que ce soit tout petit.
Là, fais un gros coup.
- Quand j'ai commencé la synchro,
il y en avait un, à Longjumeau.
Il y en avait un garçon
et je ne m'en souviens pas vraiment.
C'est marrant.
Je me souviens à peine de lui
aux exhibitions, aux compétitions.
Je ne pense pas
qu'ils l'aient mis en avant.
Ils ne l'avaient pas mis
dans notre ballet,
pour le mettre en valeur
ou quoi que ce soit.
C'est ce que j'essaierai
de faire si j'avais un garçon,
même s'il n'avait pas mis le niveau.
- Sébastien, essaye de sauter.
Saute le plus loin possible.
Allez, vas-y, pousse !
Quand on me demande
mon métier, je dis entraîneur...
de natation synchronisée masculine.
Je précise.
J'en suis fière.
Puis, j'ai envie que
les gens connaissent aussi.
- Flamant rose.
Dix coupes courtes
maintenant que vous visez.
Vous rassemblez aux chevilles
et grouper, pivoter.
Grouper, pivoter.
D'accord ?
Là, vous le faites, vous allez pouvoir...
Je voulais que ce soit très masculin
et assez dur pour
les mettre en valeur
et pour mettre
en valeur leur puissance.
- Un, deux, trois...
- Tu vas beaucoup trop vite.
Il n'est pas si lent que ça, mais...
Là, c'est cinq, six, sept, huit.
Un, deux, trois, quatre, cinq.
- Comment la main ?
La paume de la main.
- Comme ça ?
- Tu ouvres la paume vers là-bas.
et tu ouvres l'autre
paume vers l'autre.
C'est ça,
la tête vers là-bas.
Un, deux, trois, quatre,
cinq, six, sept, huit.
Un, deux, trois,
quatre, cinq, six, sept, huit.
Mon premier contact
avec le Paris aquatique,
c'était en tant que nageuse.
J'étais venue au club pour nager.
Gigi m'avait fait un duo,
puis j'avais nagé
un ballet avec eux.
Elle m'a dit,
viens, ça va être génial.
L'année prochaine,
on va créer une vraie section.
Il y a un truc à lancer.
Puis, dans deux ans,
il y a encore des championnats.
Écoute, il faut qu'on se lance,
il y a quelque chose à développer.
- Fabrice fait bien le mouvement.
- On ouvre les épaules ou... ?
- Non, le but, c'est vraiment...
Je pousse et tape.
On ne se pose pas trop
la question de leur choix sexuel,
ils sont là pour s'épanouir
et ce club le permet.
En intégrant un autre club,
c'est plus difficile.
Déjà l'image de l'homme qui fait
de la synchro est assez caricaturale.
Je pense que
ça demande encore du temps
pour comprendre que des hommes
aient envie de nager dans l'eau,
comme des gens
qui aimeraient danser ou patiner.
C'est vrai que le club du Paris
aquatique revendique l'homosexualité.
Ce club veut que la liberté s'exprime,
il veut que les gens
viennent en s'épanouissant.
La liberté sexuelle.
Puis, dans le club, il y a des filles et
des garçons qui ne sont pas homosexuels.
- Si ça me fait peur de me dévoiler
en tant qu'homosexuel dans mon métier,
dans mon entourage sportif ?
Non.
La plupart ne sont pas au courant.
Comme mes jeunes,
mes petits jeunes,
ils ne sont pas du tout au courant.
Progressivement,
je les ai mis au courant.
Récemment, l'année dernière,
notamment les maîtres.
Parce que je le veux, j'assume de plus
en plus et je n'ai pas envie de me cacher.
Puis quand on vient me demander,
je n'ai pas envie de dire,
oui, j'ai une copine,
oui, j'ai quelqu'un.
Dominante jambes.
- Combien ?
- 100 mètres dos.
Dominante jambes.
Ce n'est pas bien.
Ils sont partis sur une pyramide.
Ils en sont là à peu près...
Après, ils partent sur 200m 4N.
25 éducs, 25 nages complètes.
Ils ne m'ont pas posé la question.
Je ne leur ai jamais répondu directement.
Demain, peut-être
il va me poser la question.
Je lui dirai, écoute, oui,
j'aime les hommes.
J'ai aimé les femmes,
maintenant, j'aime les hommes.
On part sur 12 fois 100 mètres.
Le premier est en crawl en faisant 53.5.
53.7.
Le deuxième, il est en quatre
nages avec l'aspect progressif.
Le troisième est en spé,
accélération dans le mouvement.
Pour les papillonneurs,
si vous voulez le faire en éduc,
vous pouvez le faire en éduc.
- Je pars du principe
que si on me pose la question,
ça dépend aussi de qui c'est.
Si c'est une personne
que j'apprécie, je ne lui cache pas.
Par contre,
non, je ne le dis pas ça.
Cela n'intéresse que moi.
Pas les autres.
- Ça, on s'en fout.
Thomas, on s'en fout.
Nous avons besoin de votre aide.
Mon rapport annuel.
- Avec Tom,
je pense qu'on se comprend bien, parce
qu'on fait exactement le même métier.
Il est maître-nageur aussi.
C'est un entraînement.
Il sait exactement ce que je veux
et je sais qu'il ira jusqu'au bout.
Il a du mal parfois à se libérer,
de par son emploi du temps.
Il cherchera toujours
à rattraper au plus vite
ce qu'il a loupé.
Fabrice,
il est discret aussi comme Tom.
Il ne dit pas grand-chose
à l'entraînement, il écoute bien.
Ce qui est dur avec Fabrice,
c'est son gros problème de rythme.
C'est un gros bosseur, Fabrice.
Je sais qu'il écoute
tout le temps de la musique,
qu'il travaille beaucoup dessus.
JP, je pense qu'il est
primordial au sein d'une équipe.
Il est tout le temps de bonne humeur
et il apporte une dynamique
à tout le monde.
Ils sont très soudés tous les trois.
C'est ce qui marche
en natation synchronisée,
c'est d'être soudé.
C'est l'esprit d'équipe avant tout.
Sinon, ça ne marche pas.
Ils cherchent toujours
à aller plus loin, tout le temps.
Ce qui est motivant pour l'entraîneur,
parce que l'entraîneur,
c'est ce qu'il recherche tout le temps.
Le fait qu'ils soient homosexuels,
ça ne me fait strictement rien.
Je trouve que ça apporte
beaucoup plus d'affections avec moi.
- Les objectifs sont
arrivés petit à petit.
On a su qu'il y avait les championnats
d'Europe gays à Barcelone
et on s'est dit pourquoi pas.
Ça serait un de nos objectifs
et, Gigi nous a envoyé un mail
avec tous les objectifs de l'année,
on va faire ça et ça.
La première étape
sera les Aquafolies.
On fera une représentation
pour les Aquafolies.
En deux, on aura
le tournoi international de Paris,
on aura le stage de natation
aux Canaries pour s'entraîner aussi
pour les championnats d'Europe.
En trois, les EuroGames à Barcelone.
- À vos marques.
- Je suis aujourd'hui la coprésidente
du Tournoi international de Paris 2008.
C'est un tournoi qui
fête sa cinquième édition.
Le but, c'est surtout une visibilité
et une intégration par le sport
de la communauté homosexuelle.
Permettre à des sportifs
qui ne se sentent pas très bien
dans leur sport de compétition,
dans les clubs "hétéros",
plutôt
de hautes compétitions,
de venir s'épanouir dans
des sports qu'ils connaissent bien.
Pas forcément faire
de la compétition de haut niveau,
mais de rencontrer d'autres sportifs.
C'est très bien perçu,
parce qu'il y a pas mal de sportifs
et d'associations hétéros
qui viennent nous rejoindre.
Parce que cette compétition,
elle est ouverte à tous.
Ce n'est pas ciblé uniquement
la communauté LGBT,
mais c'est ouvert à tout le monde,
pour un meilleur échange et visibilité.
C'est très bien perçu.
- Mon nom, c'est Isabelle Meili.
Je suis d'origine suisse,
mais ma femme est belge.
C'est pour ça qu'on habite
en Belgique, à Bruxelles.
Je fais du volley depuis presque 15 ans
avec le BGS, le Brussels Gay Sports.
Je trouve que c'est très important
d'avoir des clubs pour les gays,
parce que je trouve surtout pour les pays
où il y a encore l'homophobie,
qu'on peut se réunir et
montrer qu'on est une grande famille.
On est là pour aider
tout le monde et pour se soutenir.
Parce qu'on est seul, mais en
même temps, il faut aussi s'intégrer.
Il ne faut pas avoir trop peur de rester
naturel et de montrer qu'on est gay,
mais on est fier d'être gay.
- Je cherche Tom, comme toujours.
- À vos marques.
- Il est là-bas, je le vois.
- On y va.
- Sois dynamique.
- On se rapproche ?
Parce qu'il y a juste un pas.
- Attendez.
- Sept, huit.
Sept, huit.
- Commencez.
La mise en place est sans arrêt.
D'accord ?
C'est juste un grand...
C'est juste...
- Là, vous n'allez pas tomber ?
Il vaut mieux vous mettre ici.
- Oui.
- Ce que vous faites, quand vous arrivez,
vous vous retournez en même temps
et vous faites un pas.
Vous vous placez.
Sept, huit.
D'accord ?
Vous faites un pas en même temps.
Jambe droite.
- On arrive, on s'immobilise ?
On fait sept, huit, un, deux.
Sept, huit.
- On y va ?
- C'est bon ?
- Oui, c'est ça.
On le refait une fois.
Un, deux, trois,
quatre, cinq, six, sept, huit.
Un.
Oui.
Il faudra écouter
la musique avant de passer.
Tom gère ses nageurs.
- Ça veut dire quoi ?
- Ça veut dire que
je ne l'ai pas sous mon aile.
Là, ça va aller.
Ils vont être concentrés.
Il faudra bien qu'on les concentre.
C'est surtout ça.
- J'appelle...
- C'était un peu compliqué à gérer.
J'ai eu beaucoup de stress le matin,
car je savais qu'ils ne se rendaient pas
compte de l'impact que ça pouvait avoir.
En synchro, rien n'est plus moche
qu'un ballet complètement désynchronisé.
Pour moi.
Ils venaient de sortir
de l'eau de leur course,
de natation sportive
pour venir enchaîner un ballet.
Non, c'était un peu fait à l'arrache.
Je pense que ça leur
a servi aussi de leçon.
On ne peut pas faire 20 sports
dans une journée, ce n'est pas possible.
Puis la synchro,
c'est un esprit d'équipe.
Quand il y a la moitié
de l'équipe qui se prépare
et les autres qui sont
encore en train de nager,
c'est vrai que
ça peut amener des clashs.
- Je ne sais pas
pourquoi ils étaient décalés.
- Parce que là,
on ne peut pas mettre plus fort.
- Oui, mais là, on entend.
On entend...
Oui, tout le monde.
Vous vous mettez...
- Non, ce n'était pas top.
- Ce n'était pas top.
- Buenos dias.
- Encore 15 secondes.
Ne le fais pas trop petit.
Il faut aller chercher loin devant.
- Position coulée.
- Reste bloqué.
Hop.
On y va.
Vous vous mettez en ligne.
Rétropédalage.
Face à moi.
On avance tout doucement.
Mettez les coudes derrière.
Là maintenant, on reste sur le rétro.
Avance tes hanches, Tom.
T'es comme ça.
Avance tes hanches, Fab.
Allez, JP, jusqu'au bout.
JP, il te reste un mètre.
Pourquoi tu arrêtes avant ?
Pendant le stage,
j'ai cherché à aller loin avec eux.
Je voulais voir
jusqu'où je pouvais les pousser,
sachant que je leur donnais
une charge de travail assez importante,
qu'ils supportent plutôt bien.
Pour eux, c'est différent.
C'est un stage, mais
c'est quand même des vacances.
C'est ce qui est
le plus difficile à allier.
- Fabrice, regarde.
Il est beau.
Quel échauffement.
- Les Canaries,
c'est une semaine de sport
et de fête.
Ça, c'est très important.
C'est d'abord du sport.
Après, la fête.
Ensuite, il faut
assumer les deux côtés,
ce qui n'est pas facile.
Ce qui rajoute
un côté encore plus sport.
- JP, quand tu descends,
tu as tes mains qui sont là.
Quand tu descends,
il faut les mettre sur le côté.
Pour t'équilibrer.
D'accord ?
Ne les ramène pas complètement ici.
Pour la descente,
mettez les mains sur le côté
pour vous équilibrer.
D'accord ?
Vous pouvez couler
complètement, Tom.
Tu coules, tu remontes
et tu recommences.
- Tom, tu as raté
l'événement de la journée.
- Ce n'est pas mal.
Ce n'est pas mal.
Il est trop fier de son corps.
Je ne vais pas lui demander.
Ça va bien ?
- Ça va bien.
- Il est assez bien gaulé.
J'avoue,
il a des obliques,
mais marqué comme ça.
- Ce n'est que le début, attends.
- On n'a pas encore trouvé la cannelle.
- Non, on n'a pas trouvé
la cannelle et là, c'est assez doux.
- La banane est super bonne.
- On n'a pas encore mis les...
- JP, il est déjà 35.
Je n'ai plus mal aux jambes.
- Moi, c'est la droite.
- Si, j'ai un peu mal encore.
La droite, ça va.
- Après-demain,
ça ira mieux pour eux,
du point de vue musculaire.
Là, ils vont avoir
très mal aujourd'hui,
très mal demain encore, c'est sûr.
On n'a pas le temps
de faire des étirements après.
C'est ça le problème.
Là, je sais que
je peux les pousser encore.
Beaucoup plus.
- Gigi, j'ai des brûlures
d'estomac, c'est horrible.
- Sors, Tom.
Il reste 20 minutes.
- Dès que je me mets à l'envers, ça...
- Qu'est-ce qui remonte ?
- Je ne sais pas.
Oui.
L'eau est un peu fraîche.
Du coup,
je n'ai qu'une envie, c'est de sortir.
D'aller au soleil.
Ça va aller.
Les courbatures ont du mal à passer.
J'ai les fessiers, les adducteurs.
J'ai très mal.
Ça va passer.
- Je m'occupe bien de vous.
- Oui.
- Je les chouchoute.
- Pas si fatigué que ça,
j'arrive à tenir le cap
et ça se passe bien.
- Si ça se passe très bien,
alors, tu n'es pas dégoûté.
- Non.
De toute façon,
je me plains toujours.
J'aime bien me plaindre.
Je ne sais pas pourquoi.
- C'est celui
qui se plaint le plus des trois.
Par contre, une fois
dans l'eau, il n'y a pas de souci.
- On était vraiment
en osmose tous les quatre.
C'est vrai que ça apporté vraiment...
quelque chose de très fort au trio.
Moi, avec les trois,
c'est vrai que je me vois loin.
- Bravo !